اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي انه بالقرب من
حدود روسيا وبلاروسيا مع الغرب تحتشد قوات
تضم نحو 30000 عسكري والاف المعدات
العسكريه واضاف شوي ان عدد افراد تشكيلات
الدول غير الاقليميه في النيتو ازداد
باكثر من الضعف منذ فبراير شباط الماضي
كما اعلن وايضا تعزيز القوات على الحدود
لمواجهه ما وصفها بخطط بولنديه لاحتلال
غربيه اوكرانيا
بالقرب من حدود دوله الاتحاد يتمركز تجمع
من القوات يضم حوالي 360 الف عسكري
وثمانيه الاف مصفحه وسته الاف منظومه
مدفعيه وقاذفه الغام عدد افراد تشكيلات
الدول غير الاقليميه في حلف شمال الاطلسي
ارتفع بنسبه اثنين ونصف منذ فبراير من
العام الماضي وتجاوز 30 الف شخص المخاطر
الحاليه ترتبط بعسكره بولندا التي اصبحت
الاداه الرئيسيه لسياسه الولايات المتحده
المناهضه لرو